thank you thank you christian
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
today
who is releasing our updated strategic
preparedness readiness and response plan
for kobe 19.
this is our third strategic plan for
kobe 19
and it could end
should be
our uh it should
it could and be should be our last
it lays out three possible scenarios for
how the economy could evolve this year
based on what we know now
the most likely scenario is that the
virus continues to evolve
but the severity of diseases it causes
reduces over time as immunity increases
due to vaccination and infection
periodic spikes in cases and deaths may
occur as immunity wanes
which may require periodic boosting for
vulnerable populations
in the best case scenario we may see
less severe variants emerge
and boosters or new formulations of
vaccines wouldn't be necessary
in the worst case scenario
a more violent and highly transmissible
variant emerged
against this new threat people's
protection against severe diseases and
deaths either from prior vaccination or
infection
will wane rapidly
addressing the situation would require
significantly altering the current
vaccines
and making sure they get to the people
who are most vulnerable to severe
diseases
so
how do we move forward
and and the acute phase of the pandemic
this year it requires
countries to invest in five
core components
first surveillance laboratories and
public health intelligence
second
vaccination public health and social
measures and engaged communities
sir
clinical care for profit 19 and
resilient health systems
for
research and development and equitable
access to tools and supplies
and fifth
coordination
at the response transitions from an
emergency mode to long-term respiratory
business management
have all the tools we need to bring this
partner under control
we can prevent transmission with masks
distancing hand hygiene and ventilation
and we can save lives by ensuring
everyone has access to tests treatments
and vaccines
equitable vaccination remains the single
most powerful tool we have to save lives
striving to vaccinate 70 percent of the
population of every country remains
essential for bringing the pandemic
under control
with priority given to health workers
older people
and other at-risk groups
i'm surprised that there are some in the
global health community who see the 70
percent target as no longer relevant
many high and middle income countries
have reached this target
and have seen a decoupling between cases
and does
even as some high-income countries now
roll out forced doses for their
populations
one-third of the world's population is
yet to receive a single dose
including 83 percent of the population
of africa
this is not acceptable to me
and it should not be acceptable to
anyone
if the world's rich are enjoying the
benefits of high vaccine coverage
why shouldn't the world spawn
are some lives words more than others
even as we continue to respond to the
pandemic
who is also putting in place new
measures to help keep the world safe
against future epidemics
today
we're launching a new strategy to scale
up genomic surveillance globally for
pathogens with epidemic and pandemic
potential
and tomorrow
we launch a new global strategy for
arbor viruses the family of viruses
spread by mosquitoes that includes
dengue
zika chikungunya and yellow fever and
which pose a threat to more than half
the world's population
now to ukraine
who continues to work with local and
international partners to deliver
medical supplies
to the hardest hit areas across ukraine
who has now delivered about 160 metric
tons of supplies
we continue to urge for guarantees of
safe passage to deliver supplies
to mary paul and other besieged cities
we have also issued guidelines for
donations including a list of critical
supplies
for which support is urgently needed
we are outraged that attacks on health
care are continuing
since the beginning of the russian
federation's invasion there have been 82
attacks on health care resulting in at
least 72 deaths
and 43 injuries
including patients and health workers
attacks on health care are a violation
of international humanitarian law
and must stop immediately
now to afghanistan
in qatar this week i'm participating in
too many things that are seeking to
elevate the suffering of afghanistan
people
yesterday
i joined the meeting convened by who and
unicef to discuss how to address
afghanistan's health needs
and tomorrow i will address a high-level
pledging event on supporting the
humanitarian response in afghanistan
over 24 million people will need
humanitarian assistance this year
they face displacement drought food
insecurity and malnutrition
coffee 19 and many other health
challenges
last year's conflict led to major
disruptions to essential services and a
significant exorcist of health workers
women and girls are especially at risk
from lack of access to health services
and lack of access to education
last week's decision
by the taliban leadership to ban girls
from school
is very troubling
who remains on the ground
and we remain committed to protecting
and promoting the health of the people
of afghanistan
we need donors to do the same
investing in the health and education of
afghanistan is an investment
in the future
of people who have suffered so much
and now to ethiopia
we welcome last week's declaration of a
humanitarian truce in chicago
and we hope that it will lead to rapid
restoration of public services including
electricity telecommunications banking
and healthcare
however
a week has passed since the truth was
announced
but no food has been allowed into
cigarettes
every hour makes a difference
when people are starving to death
no food has reached rice since
mid-december
and almost no fuel has been delivered
since august of last year
the siege of six million people in
chicago and ethiopian forces for more
than 500 days
is one of the longest in modern history
sustaining what's response to all of
these emergencies from the coveted 19
pandemic to ukraine afghanistan ethiopia
and more requires the generosity of
donors
under who's global health emergency
appeal for 2022
we require 2.7 billion us dollars to
save lives and elevate suffering around
the world
finally
let me end with some good news
the kobe 19 pandemic has demonstrated
the importance of every country having a
reliable supply of quality assured
and safe medicines and vaccines
supported by a strong national regulator
yesterday who approved egypt and
nigeria's medical products regulatory
authorities as being at maturity level
three
this means that these regulators are
performing well against a set of more
than 260 indicators
from authorizing medicines and vaccines
to testing
market surveillance and the ability to
detect adverse events
egypt and nigeria join ghana and
tanzania as having stable and
well-functioning regulatory systems in
africa
and there are several other regulators
currently under assessment
in all regions
getting to this level requires
significant investment
and we thank the governments that are
engaging with wgo for their commitment
including singapore which was approved
as maturity level 4
last month
these assessments are typical of much of
wh's work
it doesn't get many headlines
but it makes a massive difference to a
country's ability to deliver medical
products that are safe
effective and that meet international
standards
for quality
christian
back to you
thank you very very much
dr tedros with this we open the floor
for questions and let me remind you in
order to get into the queue for
questions please use the raise your hand
icon on your screen
um the first question goes to adam
miller from cbc
adam please unmute yourself and for the
others also please don't forget to
unmute yourself adam please go ahead
thanks for taking my question
uh the director general just said that
equitable vaccine remains the single
most powerful tool we have to save lives
canada was ready to donate 20 million
doses of the medical vaccine to kovacs
why did the who not approve that
medication vaccine despite the need for
more safe and effective covet vaccines
globally
and when will you decide whether or not
to adjust your policies on health
products linked to the tobacco industry
thank you very much and we give to dr
marian hill a similarities
sorry sorry thank you adam for the
question first of all let me say that we
we do have a difference in this year in
terms of supply because we we have a
last year we had a very supply
constrained environment and this year we
are seeing
that supply has stabilized through
kovacs and we are pretty much managing
the the demand from all countries in
relation to the vaccines that they they
want to to
to be delivered through the partnership
in the case of medical the process for
the emergency use listing is still
on hold for us to assess better how wgo
manages the engagement of this tobacco
industry we are seeing an increasing
trend globally of the tobacco industry
diversifying their portfolio by in in
engaging with the pharma industry so
this process is still on hold but we
should have a decision on the
continuation or not of the process in
the next few weeks thank you but let me
see let's reiterate that the supply
situation has stabilized we now need to
work on on equitable access and maybe my
colleague bruce can
can uh
compliment on this thing
i think to the point that the director
general made in his uh in his opening
remarks and then by marie angela we're
now in a situation fortunately where
we can meet the demands of
low low middle-income countries in terms
of both the volumes of products that
they want and the type of products that
they want at least in the near term and
that's great news as marie angela has
highlighted the big challenge right now
is ensuring that they have the support
needed to be able to deliver those
vaccines to get them into arms i think
as all of you are aware on this call
well vaccines were held back from low
and low middle income countries for the
first nearly you know six months plus
that they were available to high-income
countries that allowed all sorts of
problems to fester number one incomplete
preparations because they weren't sure
the vaccines were coming then rumors
were fostered etc until there's a big
hill to climb to try and make sure that
the people who really need these
vaccines and low low middle-income
countries get them so our full focus
right now is on trying to help countries
to solve those logistical
and other problems financing problems to
be able to roll the vaccines out and
again as marie angela highlighted our
focus is very much on using the
available supply there have been of
course
we're in discussions with everyone who's
interested to donate vaccines etc again
to optimize that in the context of the
uptake in countries
sorry just complimenting that we we do
have 10
other vaccines being assessed for
emergencies listing at the moment
besides the one that are already
approved the processes continue with
other vaccines as well
just to ensure that
there is enough and there is supply
coming now
thank you very much also for these
important clarifications
next question goes to lauren sierra from
the swiss news agency
please unmute yourself
yeah thank you christian for taking my
my question um the swiss government
stated this afternoon that we've reached
a normal situation and decided to lift
all the remaining
restrictions on friday so that means
no mandatory mask on the public
transportation and health center
and no mandatory isolation for the
positive cases
so as you've been vocal in the recent
weeks against a bunch of countries for
their behavior what's your comment on
that
thank you much i think we'll start with
dr mike ryan
mike ryan
and if we can't get to him maybe we can
ah here we go here we go yes we do yeah
okay sorry
some gremlins here um
maria we may we should comment on this
as well um
i think we've said consistently that the
countries that have achieved high levels
of vaccination as the dg just alluded to
have the benefit of being able to open
up
uh over the last number of weeks and
months we've obviously advised that that
is done carefully and consistently with
the previous strategies because
depending on the con the strategy that
countries had before
in terms of the level of exposure their
population has had
opening up rapidly
and removing all restrictions almost
definitely results in a rebound
in infections the question is what
impact that rebound will have
um we've seen the impact that the
sublineage ba2 has had in asia and it's
increased transmissibility and we're
seeing now i think some increased
pressure in health systems in europe
because of that virus
having that extra degree of
transmissibility
and a lot of re-infections so
even in the context of this being milder
in terms of the population being
protected more there's still a chance
that there can be pressure in the health
system so each and every government has
to look at that they have to make some
choices
around that and what they advise people
to do
what we hope governments aren't doing is
passing back that individual
responsibility onto individuals and
and not supporting people who want to
continue taking uh taking precautions
particularly people themselves who may
be vulnerable so i'm not aware sorry i'm
traveling at the moment i'm not aware of
the switch in the swiss
regulations but certainly from my own
personal perspective i will continue to
to wear my mask on the number eight bus
when i'm coming to work and i think each
and every person has to make their own
decision regarding their risk and their
exposure and potentially their
chance of exposing others so um maria
managed to comment
more specifically but again we caution
governments to be very careful to lift
uh restrictions
smoothly gradually step by step and in
accordance with the capacity of the
health system to cope with any rebound
infection
thank you much
dr
um thanks so just to supplement what
mike um was saying there i mean
countries are in very different
situations globally um and they're going
to have to set the policies that fit
their needs but we what we are saying is
to be cautious um what we are seeing at
a global level is intense circulation of
the omicron variant ba.2 in particular
um an
increasing proportion of ba.2 around the
world among the sequences that are
shared
so our recommendation and continue
continues to be and you'll see in our
updated strategic preparedness readiness
and response plan that was just
published online
and what the dg spoke to is about a
comprehensive approach we need several
elements to not only save lives now
which is primarily focusing on getting
vaccination and vaccines to those who
need them most in all countries reaching
that 70 target but 100 percent of
vulnerable people 100 of frontline
workers we also need to reduce the
spread
if we don't focus on reducing the spread
as well we will continue to see further
virus evolution and the future of future
variants is uncertain um it could be
more severe it could be less severe um
and we need to prepare for all of those
eventualities so we recommend agile
approaches we recommend tailored
approaches and i'm calling in from dubai
right now after spending some time in
manila and spending some time in
cambodia and looking at how different
countries are still wearing their masts
still trying to distance as much as uh
reasonably possible while getting back
to their lives but also focusing on
increasing vaccination we can do this we
can do this by using
appropriate tools to save people's lives
and reduce the spread so our
recommendations remain to be cautious
and as mike has just said individuals
will need to take those decisions i will
also continue to wear my mask um
religiously when i'm out and when i'm
around others um and we just need to do
what we can to save people's lives and
reduce the spread back to you
christian thank you very much maria next
question goes to simon octava from
today's news
africa simon please unmute yourself
thank you christian for taking my
question this i'm on a octavia with
today news africa and washington
president biden just returned to
washington from europe a few days ago
where he went to rally support for
ukraine and pledged more financial
support for the displaced people there
i was just wondering since the w.h.u is
still in need of funds to assist the
vulnerable population in ukraine
afghanistan and segregate ethiopia
are you in contact with the biden
administration to get those funds from
other countries and also on the crisis
in tigre and ukraine is a who in touch
with prime minister abby ahmed ali of
ethiopia or russian president vladimir
putin
for safe passage to be able to reach the
people in need thank you
thank you very much simon and i guess
we'll go to
mike dr mcgrane um
for the emergencies
you're on mute
thank you simon um no we've been uh very
heartened by the response of many donors
to the ukraine response again i said
previously the horror and the outcry
over ukraine has resulted in
who receiving or having pledged almost
100 of the funds that we we need in the
short term and we'd like to thank the
governments who've stepped forward to
make those commitments and transfer
those funds other very important crises
around the world remain underfunded
and some of them hugely underfunded so
we're still not making
making enough money available to ease
the suffering of people
all around the world
the u.s government have been uh generous
in their financial support for the
cobalt response and continue to be
through usaid and the
the the emergencies uh part of the of
of the state department very very
generous and many many
emergencies around the world
and we have met
myself in ted ross with samantha power
with sarah charles with numbers numerous
officials in the us system continue to
provide a lot of core support to what
we're trying to do around the world in
emergency response
so we thank them for that in terms of
contacts with governments we operate uh
through the united nations system
through the office of coordination of
humanitarian affairs through the the
undss security architecture as well and
we rely on our um partners to negotiate
the kinds of access that we need uh
we're
extremely agile and and willing to use
any opportunity to get medical support
to get assistance to get supplies uh
into any uh places that we can and we've
managed to get supplies and ian may wish
to speak to this
in terms of the specific
supplies we've been able to send in but
i know we've supplied uh kevin park even
uh her son and many other places over
the last number of weeks in in ukraine
um and
that has been organized also facilitated
by the u.n
and and other officials but
we don't engage at the moment in direct
negotiations uh uh regarding access we
work through our un partners to do that
uh but then at a local level uh our
frontline staff will work with other
partners to try and ensure access to
local areas so we rely very heavily as i
said
on the un and on our other states to
assist with us uh to make sure that we
can get access again we speak
about ukraine there's a tremendous focus
on ukraine and rightly so
but as dr fedras has said there are many
other areas in the world in which we
have real access issues
and
tigray have been the most acute at the
moment in terms of getting even the most
basic access to get the most basic
supplies get the most basic food
products into that situation so when we
see populations in ukraine integrating
and other countries we just basically
have
zero access
to life-saving interventions it's it's a
world of a difference between that and a
conflict situation where we struggle
to get aid and assistance in because of
conflict and all sides are trying to
help in in a way
and we struggle just because of the
conflict it's a very big difference
between that situation and the situation
in which access is being actively denied
to a population where the actual cutting
off of people is part of
part of the tactics it's part of the the
military strategy
this is what's so unusual about
situations like we see in in in ukraine
like we see in tibet
this is not people caught up in the fog
of war it's not people just caught up in
a conflict it is people being directly
targeted
directly denied and directly used as a
strategic
implements as chess pieces on a horrific
murderous board
that that
that they have no uh right uh or no need
to be on so
i think there's a huge difference when
we look at these different conflict
situations
of
of why people huge numbers of people end
up in these situations
is and i think the world needs to look
at
why
we do end up with so many groups of
people being used as pawns
and pawns of war
it's it's very hard to understand quite
frankly
thank you very
much to mr ian clark the incident
manager for ukraine
thanks uh and just to to add to what
mike was saying um simon to your
question but specifically for for
ukraine so in terms of our funding need
we went out with uh an emergency appeal
for the first three months asking for 57
million to cover both ukraine but also
the support to refugees in in hosting
countries
and thanks to the the generous
contributions from multiple donors
including the u.s
we we have close to 100 of the funding
that we were asking for
and of course that's for the initial
three months we're now in the process of
working with our health partners both
for ukraine and the hosting countries to
come up with a comprehensive
strategic response plan that will cover
the healthcare needs for ukrainians
regardless of of where they are located
both in ukraine or in hosting countries
and that will provide a longer term
outlook in terms of the the specific
activities the
funding requirements across the the
different health sector partners um for
for probably a year we're working on the
exact time scale just in terms of the
delivery you're notwithstanding the
access issues
we have been successful in in the last
couple of days of reaching uh people in
need in the east of the country
obviously that's where the greater need
is
in the last two days we've been able to
dispatch more than 21 metric tonnes to
eight locations
all in in areas which are contested we
tried to get into mariopol
we have been unsuccessful to date
together with our interagency partners
but we have been able to access places
like chiasson and of course we will
continue to try to to access those areas
thank you very much and maybe to mention
that on social media we've been
distributing a nice overview map which
shows where where distributions and
deliveries were able to reach
uh thank you mr clark
and next question goes to isabel sacco
from fa isabel please unmute yourself
thank you very much good afternoon to
everyone
it's about the lockdown in shahi
and i would like to know if you consider
that this is an effective
decision to control the outbreak
um there or if we
[Music]
we have now the tools that would allow
to avoid this kind of restrictive
measures
and if it would be better to to take
another kind of measure measures and a
lock down
um in
in
briefly is uh do you consider that this
this is a cost benefit a good cost
benefit good measure
and also and i would like to have an
update on the situation of the vaccines
um you mentioned that there are
ten candidates now uh but in the puppy
line so
are these candidates already
made or will be made to block the
omicron variant
thank you
thank you very much isabel and we're
starting with the shanghai
question first and go to
dr mike ryan again for a start and then
most likely to
whatever kirkov
background please
microwave
okay we might go to marie as well uh we
might give more details on the situation
in china
i think the
the
authorities in china have taken
you know had a very strong
approach to suppressing transmission
over a two-year period in this pandemic
and and
those insiders can argue
if that was the right approach or not
but when you look at it in terms of
numbers
very very low attack rates very low debt
rates very low hospitalization rates
and in the situation where society and
the economy could continue to function
pretty much well through the pandemic
obviously as you then come to the the
latter parts of the pandemic or what we
hope are the latter parts of the
pandemic you then have to have an exit
strategy when you have a higher
proportion of your population that are
uh potentially susceptible to disease so
that exit strategy for any country
has to be careful especially
when you've been so successful up to
that point uh
the prime minister of singapore spoke
during the week that was an excellent
description of how a country that's had
a very aggressive approach to
suppressing transmission then exits and
gets out of that situation and i've said
it before
each country comes down the mountain in
a different way
and it's very important that you don't
stumble and when you're tired and
fatigued and you're at the end of a
process it's easier to make mistakes and
make errors so i think the gov the
authorities in china are
trying to in a sense there's a billion
people in china it's one seventh of the
world's population it's very important
that that population of citizens exit
this pandemic successfully and i believe
having a stepwise data-driven approach
to doing that
is the best way forward and i'm sure the
chinese authorities will define a
strategy that allows them to exit
safely with their population having
maximal protection while re-engaging
with social and economic life and it's
always a balance every country has had
to strike this balance right away
through the pandemic
and i believe there are some very smart
people in china good scientists good
public health practitioners who can
advise government on how best
uh to to create that exit strategy uh
and sustain that strategy over time and
bring one billion people
through the end of the pandemic we hope
with the same successes which they've
managed the first part
thanks mike you know i mean i think a
lot of countries are struggling right
now um to to get themselves out of their
current situation we're in the third
year of this pandemic and this virus has
a lot of energy left it's circulating at
such an intense level tens at least 10
11 million cases being reported each
week and we know that's an underestimate
because surveillance has changed testing
has stopped or reduced significantly in
a number of countries and has as
countries
find their way through this
and find a way to responsibly manage
covet 19.
um
it's challenging um and what we what we
are hoping to see going forward is to
strike that balance
to reduce the spread but also to save
lives and what we hope not to see is
this pendulum swing of all or nothing
lifting everything and having ore having
everything in place um and really try to
tailor the approach
um to use a layered approach
um
and adjust as necessary we are not here
to sit and criticize what we're here to
do is to help and to support governments
we issue the evidence-based policies we
look at the science we're all looking at
the same data um but the policies that
countries implement um even at
sub-national levels uh need to take into
consideration a number of factors what
their current class and current strategy
is
what population level immunity looks
like from past infection but also from
vaccination and in particular looking at
the coverage of vaccination among those
who are most at risk
looking at how they have access to other
life-saving tools how they use those
tools how they adjust them
what kind of engagement and empowerment
they have of their populations and how
this varies over time we're all
exhausted from this everyone around the
world is um but unfortunately we're not
out of it and this is what we as an
organization as who with partners are
trying to do as well what's the right
balance of getting it right
um and adjusting that as we move forward
so we'll continue to support countries
in that but um we do know that vaccines
work the covid19 vaccines work at
preventing severe disease and death
including against omicron
and in particular ba.1 and b82 which is
becoming dominant worldwide um but as we
move forward we need to look at how
vaccines continue to be used going
forward but we can say that they are
robust
and strong against preventing severe
disease and death they don't prevent all
infections they don't prevent all unrun
transmissions but they're not designed
for that so that's why we need vaccines
and the not vaccines only
thank you very much
karkov and for the second part which was
under 10
ul or emergency use listed vaccines uh
dr maria angela simal please
thank you maybe my dear yes answer part
of the the issues because we actually
need all vaccines that work we need
vaccines that are effective against the
variance and that are affected against
multiple variants the the emergency use
listing process it's an assessment of
the quality of manufacturing of uh
efficacy and safety
and this so
this is very important because we
at the state we are right now we need
different platforms these 10 vaccines
that i mentioned
that are being assessed right now they
are also of different platforms
so again we need vaccines that are
more effective to even prevent in
transmission and we need vaccines that
also
focus on multiple variants so this is
the state we are right now thank you
thank you very much and let's move on
with
yeah i just want to come in quickly
because such an important point that was
raised but it's just an opportunity to
reaffirm that the vaccines that we have
now work extremely well to achieve our
primary goal which is reducing of course
severe disease and death taking saving
lives number one taking pressure off the
health systems number two and ensuring
societies and and economies can function
again as close as possible to normal so
i think it's important that we really be
super clear these vaccines almost every
one of them for which we have data on
that appear to do a great job preventing
severe disease and death irrespective of
the of the
of the variant that we're facing so the
important thing right now yes maintain
the r d agenda of course but the key
thing is the point dr tedros made in his
opening comments it's getting more doses
into more people as quickly as possible
thank you much doctor with a very
important addition and apologies uh
for not catching it immediately the next
question goes to daniel payne from
politico danielle please unmute yourself
hey thank you for taking my question um
the director general talked about the
who's sticking to the 70 goal of
vaccinating all populations but as he
said there are other groups that are
looking to move away from that to just
90
of high-risk populations i'm wondering
what would the impacts be if more groups
did that moved away from that 70 goal
um
and is the who agreeing to
that 90 goal of at risk populations as
an intermediate goal on the way to 70
um including boosters which is um what
that university report advocated for
thank you
very much thank you very much daniel and
i think we start with dr bruce elwood
daniel thanks so much and thanks
especially for how you frame the
question so to the first point you know
what happens if more groups move away
well if more groups move away from uh
from from 70
target we have more transmission in the
world we have more people that get sick
we have more people that die and
eventually we have more variants that
emerge and possibly frustrate all the
progress that's been made so far through
incredible cooperation around the world
to try and get out of this crisis so it
is a uh it you know it's it's it's it's
a it's short-sighted because right now
the bottom line daniel is we simply
don't know this virus well enough
there's lots of uncertainty and in the
face of that uncertainty what we do know
is the virus will continue to evolve
what we do know is it will continue to
surprise us and what we do know is if
people are not vaccinated they will pay
the consequence of those surprises and
what we're worried about is exactly what
the director general said is we're
now that the north is largely protected
there's this emerging
narrative that maybe you don't need that
same level of protection everywhere in
the world and that logic is difficult to
follow um yes there may be choices that
countries want to make but those are the
decisions of of uh of those countries um
and to your question daniel important
one as well you know do we uh uh
transcribe to the goal of 90 you know i
in in in the highest populations i don't
want to be the one who decides which you
know ten percent don't get the vaccine
among high-risk populations everyone
needs to be offered the vaccine among
you know the health care workers the
high-risk populations etc and as we move
down from that now in in you know every
time we say well let's make it ninety
percent let's make it eighty percent
let's say seventy percent we bring that
number down you know what are we doing
are we making it easier for us uh to hit
a target we're making it easier for the
virus to continue to spread have to be
super clear there are consequences every
time we notch these things back and the
wrong people are going to pay the price
for those consequences it won't be the
people who are ascribing to to those
changes so
for all of those reasons we remain very
much that the right thing from a public
health view is to get as many people to
vaccinate it as possible to reduce the
amount of disease suffering death and
get the world back to normal we don't
subscribe to the view that there should
be a different
standard for
people in rich countries versus others
and remember having this conversation at
a time when globally 64 of the world has
had at least one dose and 60 has had two
doses of vaccines high-income countries
we're having this conversation now at a
time when high-income countries have 80
percent of their population covered with
one dose and 75 percent with two in even
upper middle income countries 76 with
two uh doses you know it's it's the
low-income countries 11 and now we're
starting to say do they need to get to
70 percent if we need it for the high
and upper middle income countries we
need it for everyone
thank you very much dr brazil
next question goes to simone mccarthy
from cnn simon please invite yourself
thank you for taking my question good
evening from hong kong
it's been
one year since the release of the report
from the who led mission to wuhan
in that report there were some specific
recommendations for identifying the
origin of the virus or getting closer to
a to a good hypothesis
such as testing blood bank samples
tracing back market supply chains and
re-examining wuhan hospital patient data
i'm wondering if the who is aware of
whether china has done these studies and
if so if the results have been shared
with the who
i'm also interested about what your
expectations are for sego and for next
phase of studies into the origins does
this remain a priority thank you
thank you very much and maybe we start
with maria van krakov on this one
sure we can um i can start um absolutely
um studying the origins of this pandemic
and
being prepared or better prepared for
the next one remains a very high
priority of who and and partners around
the world scientists and public health
professionals around the world the sago
our strategic our science excuse me
scientific advisory group on the studies
of novel pathogens the origin of novel
pathogens has been meeting regularly and
they are outlining a global framework
for how
each time this does happen that there
are a comprehensive set of studies that
are done um when and where the first
cases are reported from known uh
epidemic and pandemic potential
pathogens or the next disease x um so
this group has been discussing what the
elements of those frame of the framework
are everything from environmental
studies to animal studies to human
studies
phylogenetic work all the way at looking
at biosafety and biosecurity in labs
around the world
and they also have a specific
responsibility to assess where we are in
our understanding of the origins of this
pandemic
they will be issuing their first report
to us to who in the coming weeks we're
hoping that they will be that this will
be ready soon um and what they are
starting to do and they're not finished
so i want to be perfectly clear that the
sago's work has just begun
um in their first report that they issue
it will be a preliminary report to us to
who it will not be complete and i'm
pretty sure and bold at the top it will
say this is a preliminary report the
work is ongoing it's not yet finished
but they will look at what studies have
been done since uh the who
joint china report was published a year
ago
looking at what has been completed since
then and making recommendations about
what still needs to be done what we can
say is that we still don't know the
origins fully of this pandemic and a lot
more work needs to be done looking at
market systems looking at animal trade
looking at animal susceptibility looking
at any samples that tested positive
anywhere in the world
prior to the first detection of the
cases in wuhan china in december 2019
looking
at biosafety biosecurity there's so much
work that continues to need to be done
um so this is a priority for us we have
had some updates um uh from our chinese
scientists around what work has been
done um but what we can say is that it's
not yet finished so um hopefully uh this
report will be issued to us soon and we
will be uh making uh releasing that
information as soon as possible but i do
want to reiterate again
um that this work will be preliminary
the job of the sago is not to find the
origins the job of the sago is to advise
who on studies that are necessary to
gather evidence to really better
understand the different hypotheses that
are out there and first and foremost to
outline a framework
for the study for each and every time
this happens
thank you very much maria and uh we're
coming
slowly to the end and the last question
goes to ali daniel from the npr the
national public radio
harry please unmute yourself
harry are you there can you still hear
us if so please unmute yourself
seems we have lost him
and that means we're at the end of it
for today and thank you all very much
um the
the transcript um will be posted
tomorrow and of course we'll send the
audio files and uh of this of the dg's
remarks right after the briefing
um
i thank you and i'll hand back to dr
tedros for closing
thank you thank you christian and thank
you to all members of the press for
joining us today and see you next time